we're seriously missing falcon in the
winter soldier so
let's take a look at the magic that
brought the series to life
where in the world is madrapore and how
did it come to our screens
you see that's what happens how did the
captain america battle on top of moving
trucks happen
what about how much cgi contributed to
the wakandan battle
let's take a look for what sweet jesus
we were blown away by this huge sequence
of the falcons soaring through the air
amongst other flyers and helicopters
but what made it even more incredible
was learning just how much of what we
saw was real
with falcon being one of the titular
characters in the series it made sense
that we'd see him do things we'd never
seen before
the series offered us the chance to see
just how powerful he was and well
we were definitely impressed this whole
sequence took a lot of planning and it
started with a step called
pre-visualization which looks like this
while doing this they also had a real
group of skydivers join them so they
could research how the aerodynamics
worked and to have reference to compare
to while they were creating their own
high flying scenes for the show
all these flyers we see bravely soaring
through the air
they aren't cgi those are actually some
of the world's best wingsuit flyers
creating real-life movie magic in the
sky
these flyers were also equipped with
black magic and head mounted cameras to
capture as much footage as they could to
use for reference and the show
what about the falcon himself well his
physical body was cgi'd into the shots
but the face and reactions we see
are all his the crew set mackie up on
wires to film him in the sequence so
they can incorporate his real body and
face whenever
they could this was a huge contributor
to making these shots look so convincing
as for the helicopters they are the most
elaborate cgi included in these shots
only one actual helicopter was actually
used and in that case they just used the
buck for interior shots
at the end of the day though the show
needed a specific looking helicopter so
the actors shot their scenes within the
actual buck of the helicopter
but in the final cut they replaced it
visually so
what is it we need exactly to create a
visually
stunning and dynamic sequence like this
one well first off
mackie hooked up to some wires add some
stunt people
wing suit flyers and the very best of
cgi
it definitely makes it more difficult to
be able to tell what is real and what's
been computer generated
the result is seamless
this exciting trektop battle was the
first time we saw bucky and sam working
to fight together and the process to
bring it to life was
no small feat planning for this battle
sequence against
walker's captain america began about
eight months prior to shooting
it's a massive fight and while falcon
could fly there were a lot of layers and
moving parts that needed to be taken
care of for shooting the complex
sequence
loads of shots were taken for this in
various locations and
in different ways here we see them
shooting on fake trucks only four feet
off the ground
then these shots on real full-sized
trucks not exactly what we see in the
series
all of these backgrounds had to be
digitally created so they cohesively
brought the german setting to life
fortunately for our bucky barnes his
time spent hanging off the bottom of a
truck was all created by computers
remember when captain america fell off
the truck it was quite the tumble since
he fell off in atlanta and landed in
prague
the fall was shot in the us and the shot
that they cut two of him on the road is
shot in prague
meaning both backgrounds had to be
redone digitally to show the german
mountains and nature in the background
i know the storyline of the legacy of
captain america and what it all means
made for some fascinating content in the
show
and we got to see some new versions of
that iconic suit
we were definitely blown away seeing sam
in the hybrid falcon captain suit
part of what's so impressive is how
flawless and perfectly fitted it looks
but in reality it wasn't quite so
there were actually hundreds of visual
effects added to hide these gaps around
the cowl neck of the costume
how are you going to use it john
walker's captain costume really stayed
in line with the classic
the team said they wanted to ensure he
kept the look while boosting the red to
emphasize the arrogance of the character
we think they nailed it one of the
coolest battles is definitely this
fierce and fiery scene
the actors did loads of training to
learn all the choreography and
techniques so they were able to perform
as much of the battle as they could
themselves
we do love being able to see these
actors showing off their amazing battle
skills
this sequence is for the most part
hand-to-hand combat but of course
they include these giant metal spears so
intense what's really impressive about
this battle is that there's actually
very little cgi used as we can see in
this footage
what we got is the real deal one stab
madrapore is one of the most fascinating
places we see in the show
it was definitely worth the months it
took the team looking for it
while they were looking their production
designer ray chan was inspired by some
back alleys in a small
town outside of atlanta and there they
found madrapore
it took a lot of planning but the area
wound up being the ideal place to
contain the lawless and dark city
in their research chan found an area in
hanoi vietnam where folks stepped out of
their back door onto a track that went
through and
for him it felt exactly like madrapore
so
that's how this unique element was added
the bridge we see here
inspired by a real bridge in mozambique
we also have to give a shout out to the
bar
it's an open bar which is a call back to
the bronze monkey club in the comics
these monkey skulls were created by tons
of casts their production team made
welcome to madrapore the land of small
alleys of a small town
in georgia with a bit of vietnam and
mozambique that is why we're going to
madrid
what's up with madjapur after spending
loads of time finding the perfect place
to shoot puerto rico was the answer
until there were two earthquakes and
their plan had to change
after regrouping and choosing new spots
to shoot they chose to venture to prague
the team flew out and had an amazing
week of mesmerizing locations and
exciting scenes but then
the pandemic really got out of hand and
the production had to shut down
immediately
literally a day after a hundred people
were flown back to the u.s
of course this really threw a wrench in
the plans and production had to stop
completely for many months
when the time came to finish the series
they knew they had to go back to prague
to get more shots but
of course it wasn't going to be so easy
considering they had to rearrange their
schedule
and account for the fact that people
couldn't fly back and forth so easily
not to mention they had to convince the
government in prague to allow a huge
american movie crew into the country to
film
thanks to the stellar crew and super
skilled writers they pulled off the feet
and managed to bring the series to our
screens at home
all while making sure every person
involved was safe and taken care of
the final result is pretty impressive
especially considering all they went
through while shooting
steve knew me longer and he had a plan
their names are in the title of the show
so we got to spend plenty of times with
bucky and sam
and are we ever glad we did the two of
them brought such a great friendship to
the screen and we loved really getting
to know who they were and watching their
relationship grow
especially considering their tents
passed as we can see here they
definitely look like they're having a
good time together and that chemistry
comes across
on screen too for anthony mackie the
experience working on the show was
really significant
especially because of the representation
of what it's like to be a black man in
america
they really address what carrying on the
legacy of captain america and being
decorated in those stars and stripes
would mean for him and his community
we are definitely hoping to see more of
these too soon
enjoy your ride buck no no you can't
call me that
marvel has done it again while it didn't
totally blow us away after seeing
wandavision
we're really glad that the mcu series
are continuing we were so excited to
finally see these two
totally underrated characters in the
spotlights which mcu
side character would you like to see
more of how did you feel about this show
compared to wandavision
you